today is International Women's Day a
chance to celebrate the contributions
women around the world make to society
sometimes those contributions come from
unexpected sources like a nine-year-old
girl who wrote a letter to NBA superstar
Steph Curry she wanted to know why his
shoe line was not sold to girls in the
girls section of the underarmor website
and in an interview you'll see only here
on CBS this morning Dana Jacobson brings
curry and the fourth grader together no
fractions this week nope
nine-year-old Riley Morrison is like
most fourth graders lots of homework man
chores around the house and her favorite
pastime basketball but last November
Riley's life changed forever when she
noticed basketball shoes designed by her
favorite NBA player Steph Curry
apparently weren't available in girls
sizes I was thinking like this isn't
fair
so she wrote a letter to Steph Curry I
hope you can work with under I'm ready
to change this because girls want to
rock the curry fives - yeah three months
later that letter is bringing Riley and
her family to this underarmor pop-up
store in Oakland home to Curry's Golden
State Warriors when you wrote that
letter what did you want to happen I
just wanted it to change because I
didn't think it was fair did you expect
to hear from him no expect it turns out
not only did curry read the letter but
also it inspired him and underarmor to
change the way they market the shoes to
girls but they didn't stop there they
invited Riley to design the artwork on
the inside of the latest version of the
curry six shoe I wanted to make sure she
was a part of that and so it's awesome
to be here - to see the entire store
come full-circle it's some two girls
playing basketball and then encouraging
where it's behind it I'll let you do the
honors
this pool straight down on their luck it
should be over and now it's time for
Riley to see firsthand with writing a
simple letter
Kendu school
it's definitely built of my confidence
before I wasn't very confident I was
really shy so let's definitely hope how
much pride do you take when you see that
knowing it's yours can you even describe
what that's like no that's good you did
some special read me some of the stuff
you wrote Rock the Curry's girls hoop to
be courageous what's it like to see it
like this it's a dream come true can you
imagine her age writing a letter like
that I can't first off her handwriting
is better than mine you sparked a nice
big movement for sure and we get to
representing it together that's it
especially the timing of Riley getting
her shoes is no coincidence
later tonight she'll wear these new
kicks center court at the Warriors game
on International Women's Day standing
right alongside her idol and one time
pen pal I want when I grow up to be just
like him I just want to be able to do
will at least be as good as he is he is
I want my girls to know that and have
that confidence as a father I think
that's that's a job we have every single
day to hopefully shape their perspective
that they can do whatever they
I got to do your Stefan shimmy Fe it's a
long way from shooting hoops with her
dad at their local gym not going down
right for playing ball with one of the
top players in the world that journey
was about much more than just basketball
did it teach you a lesson
at all yeah that we all have a voice and
by simply writing a letter you can make
a change it's pretty powerful guys you
owe for CBS this morning Dana Jacobson
out of Oakland California
okay favorite story my favorite story
and I love this little girl and the fact
that Steph listened to her and did
something he's a father of two daughters
yeah I just I felt so good over the last
couple days like the world's changing
and he and that a girl like that can
feel and that Steph Curry responds and
underarmour responded that way the world
is changing hitta better and now that
are saying nor that she was shy and now
that this has given her confidence and
that he had on the purple shoes - yeah
it's a nice looking shoe yes he has a
daughter named Riley if you have a
daughter named Riley and we're gonna see
more of this right and kudos to Steph
Curry's team and Under Armour because we
emailed I was emailing them for months
saying can we do this on International
Women's Day can we be there when they
meet so they followed through on this
they get it they get it I have a Riley -
who plays basketball so this means a lot
in our house yes getting a pair of those
shoes I'm buying all right I'm online
you have another reason to love some
courage yes